grenzpatrouille des ukrainischen
militärs im nordosten entlang eines
neuen schutzwalls der sollen
militärfahrzeuge abhalten sollte
russland tatsächlich den einmarsch wagen
die jahreszeit günstig der boden
gefroren hart wie asphalt der perfekte
untergrund für russische kampfpanzer
colon der schutzwall wird den feind
nicht stoppen
aber er wird helfen ihnen zumindest eine
zeitlang aufzuhalten
angst haben sie hier keine behaupten sie
so sei das nun mal im krieg
[Musik]
seit wochen bestimmt ein thema die
nachrichten
russische truppen stehen an der grenze
zur ukraine
westliche experten sagen das risiko
eines krieges ist die lage sei sehr
ernst
130 tausend russische soldaten sollen
mittlerweile an der grenze zur ukraine
stationiert sein wir sind auf dem weg zu
orten die angeblich auf putins an große
liste stehen sollen 2600 kilometer an 18
tagen vom westen in den osten entlang
der russischen landgrenze über die
zweitgrößte stadt der ukraine hark if in
das kriegsgebiet donners weiter ans meer
nach mariupol vorbei an der annektierten
krim in die millionen-metropole odessa
am schwarzen meer wir wollen wissen wie
geht es den menschen wie groß ist die
sorge vor einem einmarsch putins
serie diener bruder eine kleinstadt mit
7000 einwohnern das stadtbild geprägt
vom verfall und leerstand wer kann geht
weg
keine 50 meter vom russischen grenzzaun
liegt die deutsche von mikro und seiner
frau ludmilla sie empfangen uns mit
galgenhumor
wir werden hier zuschauen wie russen und
ukrainer sich beschießen aber wir werden
in der mitte stehen und nichts abbekommt
steht durch dazu
doch bisher sei alles ruhig erzählt uns
mit halo 2 der besten der ängste schüre
erklärungsversuch bei selbst gebrannten
wodka
es ist nicht die ukraine die krieg führt
gegen die russen sondern es sind die
amerikaner im moment
für mich hat die ukraine wird da etwas
in der nato verloren noch in
europäischen allianzen und er sieht auch
die ukraine in der verantwortung
schließlich würden doch auch die ihre
waffen auf russland richten kein wunder
also dass putin aufrüsten
[Musik]
du kommst du mir mit krieg was soll ich
tun ich muss mich ja verteidigen das
sollte man allen deutschen den
amerikanern und den europäern sehr
deutlich machen
sie haben ihre ganz eigene haltung zum
konflikt geprägt von russischen medien
im westen diese schlagzeilen mehrere
nato-staaten wollen zusätzliche
kampftruppen nach osteuropa
der konflikt mit russland beunruhigt
viele menschen in der ukraine
was hat wladimir putin vor
dimitrow probt den ernstfall
er will unerkannt bleiben
ich arbeite für die verteidigungs
abteilung sollte die stadt besetzt
werden werde ich schnell
die zweitgrößte stadt der ukraine könnte
die erste sein die von den russen
erobert werden soll spekulierte der
ukrainische präsident ende januar in
diesem fall würde die metro hier bleiben
als schläfer und unerkannt informationen
sammeln für das ukrainische militär er
ist russisch der mich wie viele
einwohner der stadt charkiw ein
wichtiges handelszentrum mit viel
industrie und damit strategisch
bedeutsam wie gehen die menschen hier
mit russlands drohkulisse um
seit 2014 herrscht krieg weil gewinnen
wir mal verlieren wir und seitdem steht
eine besetzung der stadt immer wieder im
raum archiv grenzt an die kriegsregion
im dornbusch wir könnten jedem moment
auch gesetzt werden
doch dieses mal sei seine angst größer
seine vorbereitungen laufen insbesondere
wie er seine frau und den kleinen sohn
evakuieren kann beide sollen im
kriegsfall in die west ukraine fliehen
ein plan den hier viele verfolgen doch
noch bleiben die meisten
natürlich habe ich angst aber angst
sollte niemals siegen
wir bleiben einige tage in der stadt
in der ukraine selbst wächst die angst
vor einem russischen angriff im konflikt
zwischen russland und der ukraine will
die bundesregierung auch weiterhin keine
waffen an kiew liefern die ukraine
erwartet viel mehr unterstützung ist
deutschland
vor dem stadtrat in hartz iv ein zelt
pro ukrainischer aktivisten eine foto
ausstellung erinnert an 2014 als
erstmals pro-russische milizen dörfer
und städte in der ost ukraine besetzten
das ukrainische militär hält seit acht
jahren dagegen bis heute haben
pro-russische separatisten die
großstädte donev und lohans in der ost
ukraine besetzt und eigene volksrepublik
ausgerufen die bis heute international
nicht anerkannt werden sie wollen weiter
expandieren und eine abspaltung der
region von der ukraine bewirken juli und
boris waren schon oft an der front sie
beliefern die ukrainischen soldaten und
freiwilligen mit hilfsgütern
das sind tücher zum waffen putzen
traditionelles handwerk für die front
unsere großmütter haben die bestückt
noch ist der krieg vier autostunden
entfernt im dom bass seit einigen wochen
werde an der front schärfer geschossen
die pro ukrainischen aktivisten sagen
solange europa keine einigkeit
demonstrieren und deutschland an der
absage festhalte waffen zu liefern werde
sich die situation an der front weiter
verschärfen
tatsache ist wenn wir bewaffnet wären
und noch dazu mit den guten waffen aus
deutschland dann würde das ein klares
signal an putin bedeuten eine art
stoppsignal
die deutschen sind die einzigen die
keine waffen schicken wollen dabei
sollten sie sich klar zu uns
positionieren um so putin ein klares
zeichen zu senden
die deutschen bahn für den frieden nach
dem zweiten weltkrieg
wir ukraine respektieren die deutschen
sehr und schätzen sie
deshalb sollten sie sich jetzt ganz klar
zu uns positionieren und aktiv für
boris und juli steht fest bei einem
einmarsch in hartz iv werden sie zur
waffe greifen und kämpfen bis dahin
versuchen sie ihre landsleute
frontsoldaten bestmöglich zu versorgen
mit allem was man so brauchen könnte auf
dem schlachtfeld
unterwegs richtung front
der nacht sind nahe kiew
waffenlieferungen aus den usa
eingetroffen
russland warf dem westen einen
gefährlichen eskalationskurs vor
florians spuren der andauernden kämpfe
prägen das stadtbild fast drei monate
war die stadt besetzt vom prorussischen
separatisten im juli 2014 beendete das
ukrainische militär nach schweren
gefechten die prorussische belagerung
über die narben des krieges ärgert sich
nicolai täglich
bitte schön hier haben die kugeln
getroffen
guck mal hier steckt sogar noch etwas
vom projektil drin
eigentlich wollte die stadt sein haus
längst renoviert haben doch passiert ist
nichts die großen löcher hat er
notdürftig gestopft die brüchige mauer
stoppt den winter schon lange nicht mehr
und holz ist teuer die kleine rente von
umgerechnet 100 euro deckt gerade so
seiner heizkosten die menschen hier
hätten keine kraft mehr für den krieg
sagt nicolai seit 2014 gebe es nur noch
zerstörung und leid dabei sein russen
und ukrainer doch einmal brüder gewesen
in dem sowjet zeiten lebten wir alle
zusammen kasachen
und ukraine und plötzlich wegen
irgendwelchen politikern ist unsere
union zerbrochen
und nun spitze sich die situation wieder
bedrohlich zu russland soll über 130.000
soldaten an der grenze zur ukraine
stationiert haben nikolai ist beunruhigt
ich glaube es zwar nicht aber wenn sie
wirklich einmarschieren dann wird das
der dritte weltkrieg denn niemand will
aber ich fürchte mich vor gar nichts
mehr
hat er wirklich keine angst
ich habe keine angst mehr
ich habe überhaupt keine angst mehr
er zeigt uns im hof den selbst gebauten
keller wo sie wochen lang ausharren
mussten als granaten und kugeln den tod
bringen sollten er seine frau die
tochter mit seinen zwei enkeltöchtern
noch dient der keller nur als
vorratskammer der keller ist
bombensicher
auch
jetzt
dieser keller wird widerstand hatten
androsch
die enkelinnen sind heute neun und elf
jahre alt nicolai holt sie jeden tag von
der schule ab die eltern von nastia und
katja sind arbeiten deswegen übernimmt
der oper ein heizen kochen und das
wichtigste
kinder jetzt hausaufgaben
hausaufgaben yahoo
äußerlich herrscht in den dörfern im
donbass normalität aber das trauma des
krieges ist allgegenwärtig auch bei
nastia und katja die den frieden nie
erlebt haben katja kann sich kaum an die
wochen im keller erinnern die elfjährige
nastia schon sie war drei damals
als katja klein war wurde sie von mama
in tücher eingewickelt wir gingen in
keller dann schlugen die geschosse 1
waren granaten und dann gab es eine
schießerei
ist ja keine frage mehr
weiter richtung frontier jeder schritt
von der straße kann den tod bringen
minenfelder verwaiste schützengräben
zerstörte verbindungsstraßen pavel opel
nur zwei kilometer sind es von hier bis
zur sogenannten kontakt linie erst vor
wenigen tagen sollen pro russische
separatisten das ukrainische dorf wieder
unter beschuss genommen haben auch wir
sollen uns beeilen sagen die menschen
vor ort damit wir nicht zum ziel für
sniper werden am dorfladen verabredung
mit tatjana die 58 jährige lebt hier
allein
2016 erschoss ein scharfschütze aus dem
hinterhalt ihren mann beim fischen es
war weihnachten
zuerst dorthin
es waren zwei kugeln am arm eine in die
letzte kugel hat seinen unterlässt
zerfetzt
wir begleiten sie nach hause die
trinkwasserversorgung sei schlecht im
dorf gas und strom immer wieder
unterbrochen die küche gezeichnet von
den detonationen vergangener einschläge
warum sie das dorf nicht verlassen
wollen wir wissen
ich kann einfach nicht ich liebe mein
haus ich will hier nicht weg und
das haus ist noch längst nicht fertig
außerdem ist doch das grab meines mannes
her
und was wenn es wieder losgeht
unter dem esstisch ihr schutzkeller
wochenlang haben sie und ihr mann damals
hier aus sechs quadratmeter temperatur
zwei grad
dort da habe ich gegeben eines nachts
und wollte schlafen
ich bin auch eingelegt aber dann war es
so kalt dass ich aufstand und sagte hier
komme ich nicht mehr her
sollte es wieder zu schweren gefechten
kommen werde tatjana oben im bett liegen
bleiben angst vor dem tod habe sie keine
sei die einsamkeit die ihr zu schaffen
mache und eine frage quält sie
für was
wofür musste meinen mann sterben
tatjana zeigt uns das grab ihres mannes
mindestens 14.000 menschenleben forderte
der konflikt bis heute ihr mann bisher
der einzige aus dem dorf der von
scharfschützen erschossen wurde ein
zufälliger ein sinnloser tod findet
tatjana für einen krieg da einfach kein
ende finden will
weiter ins 30 kilometer entfernte
mariupol
in der sich zuspitzenden ukraine krise
wollen die usa jetzt weitere militärs
nach europa verlegen alle seiten betonen
dass sie keinen krieg wollen
die letzte großstadt auf dem don was
unter ukrainischer kontrolle
markenzeichen das stahlwerk eines
ukrainischen oligarchen für putin eine
strategisch wichtige hafenstadt denn von
hier aus könnte er eine landverbindung
zur krim schaffen
verabredung in der kriegsmarine sollte
russland vom meer aus angreifen dann
treffen sie die achillesferse der
ukrainischen streitkräfte mit mehr als
der doppelten truppenstärke sollen
russische kriegsschiffe irgendwo da
draußen am asowschen meer warten die
eroberung von mario pohl dürfte für sie
ein leichtes werden
wir beobachten hier regelmäßig
grenzverletzungen unseres hoheitsgebiet
wir sichten täglich die kriegsflotte der
russischen streitkräfte des russischen
geheimdienstes und der schwarzmeerflotte
immer wieder kommt es zu systematischen
überschreitungen der drei meilen
kommen bis ans ufer
das sei eine offene provokation aber
mehr könne er auch nicht sagen jedes
falsche wort könne die lage bedrohlich
verschärfen an den östlichen ausläufern
von mario pohl eine fischer siedlung die
männer hier bewachen für den
ukrainischen grenzdienst den
strandabschnitt und obwohl die
russischstämmigen männer im dienste der
ukrainischen regierung stehen halten sie
wenig von einem bündnis mit dem westen
das ist eine fehde zwischen amerika und
russland und die ukraine ist ein opfer
wir wurden gewaltsam in einen konflikt
gezwungen indem wir nicht sein wollen
und jetzt an drei sagt er werde im falle
eines angriffs nicht kämpfen
[Musik]
die überwiegende mehrheit will nicht
kämpfen niemand braucht wir krieg jeder
weiß wie das enden wird und
wie soll man so seine kinder großen
switche
millionen ukraine haben seit 2014 ihrer
heimat verlassen
[Applaus]
auch alena will mit ihrem achtjährigen
sohn fliehen sollte es wieder zu
gefechten in der nachbarschaft kommen
zum ersten mal zeigt sie pascha den
flucht koffer
wenn es knallen sollte liegen wir unsere
pässe auch deiner die wirst du brauchen
hier liegt das geld die heiratsurkunde
die geburtsurkunde dokumente für unser
haus und auto
katar hat den frieden nie erlebt schon
als er geboren wurde gab es heftige
kämpfe um marihuana lena tut sich schwer
im vom krieg zu erzählen
er versteht nicht warum wir den koffer
gepackt haben und warum wir mit einem
bein in der tür stehen
doch ich verstehe das als ich meiner
großmutter spazieren war erzählte sie
mir dass unsere stadt schon einmal
beschlossen wurde ich stelle mir vor
dass dann alle schwarz weiß wird und
menschen mit maschinengewehren
herumlaufen der koffer nur eine
vorkehrung die familie hofft weiter dass
pascha eine zukunft in seiner heimat hat
unterwegs zur krim nach der besetzung
durch prorussischen kräfte 2014
entschied sich die bevölkerung nach
einem umstrittenen referendum für einen
anschluss der krim an russland diese
aktion wird von vielen staaten nicht
anerkannt
grenzkontrollstelle schon gar aljona auf
wochenendbesuch seit vier uhr morgens
ist die russen von der krim unterwegs um
ihren 14 jährigen sohn zu besuchen der
hat wegen seines vaters die ukrainische
staatsbürgerschaft deshalb darf er nicht
mehr bei ihr auf der krim leben sondern
es bei der tante auf der ukrainischen
seite untergekommen aljona macht das
wütend schuld für sie hat die ukraine
[Musik]
als ich das letzte mal die grenze
passierte sagten die ukrainischen grenze
zu mir wartet mal ab wir werden die
creme zurückerobern
also ist die ukraine der aggressor
russland auf jeden fall nicht
1 trennte aljona und ihre ukrainische
schwägerin irina nur ein kurzer fußweg
heute eine landesgrenze die familie
zerrissen die ursache des ganzen übels
sagt sie sei die methan revolution vor
acht jahren gewesen als die ukrainischen
demonstranten der pro russischen
regierung das vertrauen entzog nun wenn
damals 2014 der ehemalige präsident
einfach die armee mobilisiert hätte dann
wäre das alles nicht sooo ausgeharrt da
gab es doch keine helden auf dem majdan
ihre ansicht teilen viele russische
grimm bewohner eine bedrohung putins
spüren die frauen hier nicht
ich wohne 20 kilometer von der grenze
entfernt und habe da keinen einzigen
russischen soldaten gesehen
alles ist ruhig es gibt keine armen
leute mein konto ich mich neulich an und
sagte nehmen die kinder und fahren die
west ukraine
ich fragte ihn warum er sagte bei euch
gibt es doch panzer und sowas aber er
ist nicht
überprüfen können wir das nicht aljona
wohnt auf der araber klärung einer
landzunge die seit der annexion der krim
zerteilt ist sollte russland eine
offensive starten dann könnte diese
straße zur russischen panzer trasse ins
landesinnere der ukraine werden die
ukrainischen soldaten wissen auch um die
gefahr die vom meer aus droht aber man
habe aus 2014 gelernt
wir hoffen inständig dass putin genug
verstand hat und nicht angreift
sonst wird es sehr viele tote auf beiden
seiten gehen
tote zivilisten und tote soldaten
und so sagt er sie wollen diese
gelegenheit nutzen um endlich ihr gebiet
die krim zurückzuerobern
patriotismus stadt kriegsangst auch bei
den einwohnern viele leben hier vom
fischfang doch seit 2014 seien sie im
täglichen krieg mit den russen um
fanggebiete erzählt uns valentin er sei
wütend und sollte es jetzt zum angriff
der russen kommen dann würden sie sich
rächen
wir haben grenzer reservisten die sich
gerade organisieren ja noch waffen er
hat ein jagdgewehr ich habe eine granate
wir werden unser land die ukraine
verteidigen und putin treffen
wir werden gut ihn töten
wir zeigen sie
[Gelächter]
nach dem interview sagt uns alle knopf
eigentlich wünsche er sich nur frieden
und keinen täglichen streit mehr um die
fanggebiete
wir fahren weiter hunderte kilometer in
den westen
wie umgehen mit dem russischen
truppenaufmarsch
das diplomatische ringen um eine
friedliche lösung des konflikts ging
heute weiter
endstation odessa die metropole am
schwarzen meer fast jeder dritte hier
ist russe stämmig und die mehrheit der
bevölkerung spricht sogar russisch zu
hause
die schönste perle an der russischen
krone so nennt der volksmund die
millionenstadt strategisch wichtig hier
ist der größte hafen der ukraine
mit mühen der mondänen innenstadt ein
besetztes haus
hier hat sich slavomir einquartiert
der rentner hat am eigenen leibe
erfahren was es bedeutet wenn die
russische seite land gewinnen will
[Musik]
ich komme aus der donezk region aus der
stadt tschechiens jetzt heißt die stadt
tornetz sie wurde umbenannt
einige wochen war seine stadt vom
prorussischen separatisten okkupiert der
damals 53-jährige war in dieser zeit
panzer abwehr kommandant und bekämpfte
an der front seine ehemaligen nachbarn
vor fünf jahren dann die flucht nur
erwünscht seien er und die anderen don
was flüchtlinge hier nicht strom und
wasser hat die stadt odessa vor jahren
abgestellt die flüchtlinge stören
[Musik]
die wollen uns hier raus sagen
hauptsache raus aus dem haus
ist auch logisch das gebäude liegt sehr
gut
direkt im stadtzentrum
ich glaube irgendwer will das gebäude
haben
doch slawomir denkt gar nicht daran
seine neue heimat zu verlassen
ebenso wenig wie olga die wohnt ein
stockwerk tiefer sie ist
krankenschwester auf der intensivstation
im hiesigen krankenhaus
nach der arbeit hausaufgabenbetreuung
für den kleinen sohn im halbdunkeln
[Musik]
das schlimmste ist die kälte wir werden
an dauernd krank die kinder waren diesen
winter schon dreimal ich auf und auch
meine mutter aber wir können uns kein
anderes appartement leisten die bank
gibt uns keinen kredit wegen der hohen
zinsen
und ich bin allein verdienerin ich kann
mir das nicht leisten
olga lebt auf zwölf quadratmetern mit
ihrer mutter und den beiden söhnen und
obwohl jahre vergangen sind kommt die
familie einfach nicht zur ruhe was
werden sie tun sollte es tatsächlich zum
erneuten angriff kommen
ein zweites mal werden wir das nicht
überlegen wir sind moralisch und
physisch am ende wir sind müde vom krieg
und diesen bedingungen und wir wissen
nicht wohin sollte es noch einmal krieg
geben
wieder die heimat verlieren eine angst
die viele der hausbewohner in diesen
tagen beschäftigt
[Musik]
in der ukraine krise sendet russland
bisher kein zeichen des einlenkens
russland verstärkt derweil seine
militärpräsenz in belarus und schickt
weitere rüstungsgüter an die grenze zur
ukraine
darunter kurzstrecken abwehrraketen zu
übungszwecken wie es heißt
doch auch putin hat ein problem wer
derart laut mit den säbeln rasseln kann
sich schlecht einfach wieder einpacken
und zu sagen und klanglos abziehen im
augenblick provoziert er vor allem gegen
druck
[Applaus]
gegendruck die ukrainische nationalgarde
will der welt zeigen wir sind
kampfbereit sie lädt die internationale
presse zu militärübungen ein in die
geisterstadt pripjat
fernsehteams aus aller welt ringen um
einen platz in der ersten reihe sie
kämpfen hier um bilder bilder mit den
konflikt weiter anheizen werden
bei dem knapp zweistündigen show manöver
wird viel geboten
häuserkampf verletzten bergung
spezialtrupps und minensucher
danach minister aufgebot erst der
innenminister
[Musik]
dann der verteidigungsminister mit
beschwichtigung aufrufen die derzeitige
konzentration der russischen truppen in
belarus reiche um moment nicht aus für
eine offensive sagt der nachfrage ob
solche veranstaltungen diesen konflikt
dann nicht zusätzlich verschärfen eine
medien hysterie gar erst befeuern
meine mutter war psychiaterin sie
brachte mir von kills tagen an bei
history und panik eine absage zu
erteilen
also bitte ich alle ruhe zu bewahren und
nicht in panik zu verfallen und ja
einige medien übertreiben das ausmaß der
bedrohung deshalb bitte ich er fordere
ich die vertreter aller medien auf
einfach die wahrheit zu sagen nicht zu
verwechseln
dann wird es weniger panik und mehr
frieden auf unseren straßen gehen
die wahrheit
wir haben auf unserer reise menschen
getroffen mit ganz unterschiedlichen
meinungen ob irland die nähe zu russland
oder die zum westen suchen sollte doch
alle ausnahmslos eint ein wunsch frieden
eine lösung ohne militärische invasion
eine lösung bei der nicht noch einmal
tausende menschen ums leben kommen und
millionen ihre heimat verlassen müssen
[Musik]